how old your kid mike six so she but is
she's going to any schooling or anything
she we we she was at la unified public
schools last year in kindergarten
and just this year prior to covet or
anything we decided to take her out and
put her in
um uh a private school because daddy
um well she and she's she's she's a
weirdo my kid's a weirdo and
i grew up and i was kind of weirdo not
off on her own talking in the corner or
no no
just like she's she loves her own
outfits and has
no she doesn't care what other kids are
wearing she wears these [ __ ] up like
ace ventura when he goes to the mental
hospitals
that's cool and she she likes to create
this
insane artwork where an artist right and
a
good weird she's a weirdo she's not a
and she's wonderfully odd but
but is she an introvert
when she's not around like friends and
family yeah she's really introverted
when she's with us she's you can't shut
her up i bet
and i see so much of my daughter in
in me and i went to public schools la
unified my whole life
i had 60 some kids in my class every
class it was just massive schools
and i know that for someone like me
there was a big
one of the big reasons i was such a bad
student is because i was a shitty
student another reason was because like
i needed special attention
so my wife and i had this conversation
we're like we should get her in some
place that's a little more open-minded
blah blah blah so we put her in this
private school covet hits la public
schools are like
you're not going back to school we might
do some zoom [ __ ] figure it out but
this publix private school is trying so
hard to kind of toe the line they're
trying the best they can
to say you're gonna your kid's gonna go
to school
in september it's gonna happen but every
week we get a [ __ ] news
newsome came out because yeah my kids
are in private school and they
you know the private school was allowed
to get away with it and knew some
realized that was going on and he shut
down that
it's it and the schools are not allowed
to be open as of right now no
if they're in the if they're in one of
those hot zones yeah in california and
l.a county is one of them
but they keep sending cc's mail we have
five weeks we have four weeks there's
still so much we can do
so but you turned out fine you went to
public school i did but it was only by
the grace of god horrible drug issue but
i
and also i i honestly like i don't know
how it is now
but in in big public schools there was a
time and a place
you know when i was in high school uh in
grade school
like there was a there was a an
understood
thing like smart kids who are
are on it go ahead pay attention you
[ __ ]
just keep your mouth shut we'll pass you
just stay out of my [ __ ] way and that
was like
they looked jamie's number one don't
[ __ ] this up for the kids
and i and i very early on got this
impression that's like okay
i'm that kid and going to college and
doing
white-collar work is not for me so just
[ __ ]
do your best kill your time and then
hope to god that you can become a
fireman or
or uh get some like a good union
construction gig i had the worst
education because i was
moved all the time yeah so i just had
blinding guess i'll never forget my
father
i wrote a letter i wrote a like a thank
you letter or something
and my father proofread it i was 15. and
he looked up at me and he said
are you worth it he he just
the way you did he goes are you aware
that a sentence ends in a period i know
that's how [ __ ] idiotic i was there
yeah i did the same thing i wrote on the
computer and i had my dad proofreading
he goes
i mean he's just your dad would be the
same i can't just see him he keeps going
like this and he looks at me goes
this is terrible i was like um i was
like
all right dude well [ __ ] sorry man
public school
dude i was reading aloud and i was going
like this i was going
uh the ski was uh blue and he goes
read it again i know the ski was blue
and he goes read it again
i go the ski is blue he gets the sky
this guy
god damn it he's pulling his hair out
cause i was like this is how old were
you an idiot were you like
sorry i was like thirty twenty seven
ninety seven
[ __ ] i'll tell you what's interesting
though is like you know when your kids
going to school and you're you're
driving them and
you know that takes time and you know
they're at school and they get home
around
four you know now being home around my
kids so much it's like i get why
if you could come up with like a
curriculum where they could
learn at the home school and if you if
you have the freedom like we do with our
jobs to be around
more you get more time with them i can
see the benefits of homeschooling
there's there's
huge benefits because you you can keep
your eye on your kid and
also um there's always concern
even if you're not some super conspiracy
theory um
you know right wing [ __ ] there i i
think that there's obviously going to be
concern that like ethical and moral
ideas are going to be injected in your
kid that you don't think
you don't really especially the way
science are going right now right
exactly and then far left ideology
don't teach my my kids your [ __ ]
activist
far left idea of what you think truth is
go [ __ ] yourself
reading writing arithmetic sports art
keep your politics out of my [ __ ]
kids
i'm going to lose [ __ ] i know dude
discover america believe me i'm going to
come
i'm going to come after him i don't have
any problems right now yeah
yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue
gonna happen what are you gonna do use
some of that
boxing you've been doing